[Musique]
ensuite effectivement nous avons eu un
petit événement ainsi dans du pur au
départ en fait mais paraissait plutôt
une bonne chose et ils ont trouvé refuge
dans le jardin d'eole et place de la
bataille de stalingrad aussi qui se
trouve à 600 m du coup ils ont commencé
à consommer du crack dont la colline
face il y avait à peu près une
cinquantaine ou la soixantaine de
personnes qui consommaient de la drogue
quand ils sont arrivés ont pas de
conditions déplacer jusqu'aux jardins
d'eole et jusqu'où les deux amis grade
on s'est retrouvé avec tuto 200 à 300
400 personnes actuellement fait qu'ils
consomment du crack est donc là c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué tout le quartier
est devenu particulièrement dangereux
car on est un peu à gué aussi parce que
là où l'on marche mais au corner passé
de quoi il peut y avoir d extrêmement
bruyant ça c'est la partie la plus sale
mais il peut y avoir des trucs tu les
envoies vous avez des stores inc qui
traînent au sol vous avez des lambeaux
de pipes à crack des morceaux de verre
un petit peu partout
voilà le quartier devenu invivable qu'il
faut comprendre les riverains
je fais ce que je veux c'est ça je pense
que ça aurait besoin ont dû se dire que
j'étais une bonne idée peut-être de les
effrayer
donc ils ont tiré des mortiers tuque
mais enfin c'est pas une solution je
peur pour faire face on aille crescendo
vers une escalade s'efforcent donc on a
eu plus de policiers qui ont circulé
pendant dans les rues aux quinze jours
mais ça sert à rien ils sont pas là pour
gérer les autres qui commencent donc
nous on peut faire sur tous et continuez
d'alerté or on participe aussi donc à
une manifestation entre guillemets qu'on
appelle le 20h pétrole donc là par
contre procès au lieu de féliciter les
infirmiers des roues est débrouillé à 20
heures pour dire qu'on en a marre d'être
acteurs que nous aussi on habite là et
on fait ça serait bien que l'on va être
il habite pas là
[Musique]